coming off the best episode of the show
episode 8 the lord of the tides still
managed to be really good we do go
through a time Jump within this episode
but I don't think it was as bad as it
was in episode 6 where they skipped over
multiple plot lines and threw us into
the endpoint of a lot of them like with
Damon Targaryen and Lena's family here
in episode 8 everyone was essentially
isolated in their own locations so there
was nothing crazy that happened to
Warrant an entire episode to happen in
that time it would be nice to see some
things like the Fallout of laner's death
and the conspiracy that brings about
Alison having to rekindle her
relationship with viserys aegon having
to marry his sister we're near his kids
having to meet and get along with Damons
and that new family Dynamic eamon's
overcoming any limitations of having one
eye and maybe even some action with
Corliss in the stepsons and how he got
injured like that would be a good end
point for an episode that then leads
into this one there's enough there where
they probably could have done one
episode which would have been good but
this at least isn't the worst example of
them time Jump I just feel like this
season could have made for a great 13
episode season instead of 10 and rushing
as a result they also do give us a scene
between Rainier and rhaenys which I
think was much needed because that's
such an interesting point of conflict in
regards to laner's fake out death and
rainey's having her suspicions but I
wish that was a dress right after the
death of lanar and maybe we see the
wrath of raineys which would then be
contrasted with this scene where she
cools down to spend multiple years since
that event and from my understanding
they'll be easing off on the time jumps
because we've essentially arrived at the
meat of the story now with that one
negative aspect out of the way this
episode only has upsides from here I
want to address by far my favorite
aspect which is visceros Targaryen and
basically every scene for this episode
The culmination of all his rots and
every small detail that has been
building throughout the season from the
subtle way he acts his energy appearance
the way he holds himself walks and even
breathes has been utterly exasperated
now he's at the peak of his illness and
he's practically a different person the
transformation of his character from the
first episode to this one is just
astounding I also love how they're using
VFX in this episode to make his
appearance even worse on top of
everything like this shot where he's
shirtless and his body was so skinny
makes viserys seem alien-like I don't
know if the VFX here was obvious to
everyone but it doesn't bother me at all
because the way they were utilizing it
was really cool along with his face
reveal where he's missing an eye and
part of his right cheek it really AIDS
Patty Constantine's performance and
makes him mesmerizing to watch and his
General design with his new mask brings
back his powerful image although I do
wish the mask looked more metallic
because it looks pretty plasticky but
besides that his character designed in
terms of body Decay has been extremely
detailed and thought out so that paired
with an already great performance will
probably earn this man an Emmy or at
least get nominated he's just so
believable in this role that I'm always
immersed in by by the fact that this man
is on his last legs and it also seems
like Patty is giving his performance
with relative ease even after a grueling
take of him limping down the throne room
in pain he then gets up and starts
messing around like I just love this
visual so much which going into this
scene is kind of ironic in a sense how
visar showing up in the throne room was
such a shocking moment the amount of
strength on display here is really
staggering and the writing I think is
impeccably done in this moment because
up until his arrival reniro is basically
fighting a losing battle Alison and Otto
are clearly biased and vaman has a good
point in that he wants the blood of
valerians to stand the Throne of
driftmark up to this point we are
basically ruling out that visceros won't
be able to help rhaenyra so it was a
great twist for him to suddenly show up
here this may technically count as a
deus ex machina which in of itself I
find funny that this limping man is deus
ex machina to begin with but it was set
up that he expressed the interest in
having dinner so it's believable for him
to show up since he may have a burst of
energy there are two other aspects that
really sell this moment which is where
mean jawadi's Triumph and score and the
director dedicating an entire four
minutes of visares just limping to the
throne this long duration really sells
his struggles and without the music to
punctuate how big of a deal this is that
it wouldn't have been as Grand like
imagine the scene without the music and
it's just if it starts limping across
the throne room a flat out wouldn't work
so Ramin jawadi is great as always and
even has another moment to shine later
on in the episode but since we are in
the scene we may as well address the
elephant in the room which is vaymond
valerion it was so satisfying for him to
get mad and finally drop the bomb of
calling Rainier's children bastards it
kind of happened in the last episode but
it wasn't as explosive because aegon was
kind of awkwardly calling attention to
the fact that they look nothing like
valerians but here Damon is so
emotionally charged that it's immensely
satisfying when he yells that word and
it echoes throughout the throne room
oh bastards
the craters also gave Raymond quite a
bit of screen time before this scene to
build up this moment and even before
this episode it was always leading here
this is kind of like a mirror to vaman's
eulogy where he's expressing this notion
through his eyes but in this episode
he's getting verbal now for vaman to
yell this in court in front of the king
is pretty suicidal and can be seen as
dumb but he seemed pretty overcome with
emotions to the point that rational
thought left his brain then Damon takes
advantage of this and kills him that was
just a perfect moment for Damon to be
Damon and essentially one-ups his
brother in terms of dishing out
punishments any death in Game of Thrones
and House of dragon is so great and I'm
excited to see more because this one was
like crack then for the other standout
scene of the episode we have the last
supper and to be honest I got pretty
teary-eyed in this scene and what is not
expecting that at all I just felt so sad
for viserys in that brief moment of
light he Witnesses where he dies knowing
that his family rekindled and are happy
is such a precious moment that I
couldn't help but almost shut to tear
over that in this moment is definitely
aided by the fact that Ramin djawadi is
slaying it on the violin which on its
own would probably make me cry anyways
so the pairing of these two aspects was
like a perfect storm to make me break
down in this moment and it's also not
just seeing viserys's last happy moment
in life but it's also the Calm before
the storm this is the final good moment
these characters will share together
before the knives start to come out so
it's nice to kind of live in this moment
and witness what would be in a perfect
world without George R Martin coming in
to eviscerate everyone's dreams this one
minute is definitely one of my favorite
moments in the show so far and it's pure
beauty is like an instant injection of
Happiness within my brain but this
moment can only last so long because the
boys gotta get out their testosterone
and fight this leads me to want to talk
about eamonn's because Jesus Christ this
guy looks like a psychopath now his
little smirk is so unsettling like
honestly the older versions of Eamonn
and aegon look nothing like their
younger selves but I can live with that
because Eamon is going to be a very
interesting character going forward
especially since they're kind of setting
up something between Damon and Eamonn
but I like how they hold back in the
scene and Eamon doesn't lash out after
getting hit they are just slowly holding
off on that until [ __ ] actually goes
down later then the final scene wasn't
really able to hold the momentum of the
last scene and it ended on a bit of a
Down note to me I don't really like how
visceros was just rambling on about the
prince who has promised again and
Allison interpreted that as him talking
about aegon like I know she'll basically
take anything at this point as an excuse
to seize the throne for her family but
come on the man is just rambling and she
should know this it comes across to me
as the writer's kind of manipulating the
audience to feel like everything is fine
just for it to not be and the reason for
it to go Rye was kind of silly even
though it makes sense I just wish they
had a better reason for Allison to latch
on to contest renera rather than her
listening to her husband blindly ramble
about something that he probably does
every night but whatever now I'm kind of
associating Game of Thrones to why all
the bad things are happening in House of
the dragon and that's not a good thought
either before ending there were a couple
other notable aspects in this episode
that I liked which was the execution of
Dragonstone and how Allison has changed
since the time Jump before she came
across as being very rash and quickly
swayed by her emotions so the point of
her making grave mistakes but now it
seems like she's learned from that and
is more patient and laid back than
before and thinks before she acts
besides when she's interacting with
aegon because that guy deserves it then
for Dragonstone the design of it in this
show is much cooler than Game of Thrones
because they're actually in a volcanic
area before it never really felt like
that and was only expressed in the
design of the castle in House of the
Dragon the sound design here is also
much better you hear the crisp sizzling
of the fire and steam permeating in the
background the subtle Breeze of them in
a big hole and the Bassy booms of the
Waves crashing on the beach it really
amalgamates into a feeling of this place
being real when the sound has so much
depth to it
and landed
I wish we'd get some more scenes here
but it seems like we'll be in King is
landing on the next episode which isn't
to discredit the other sets because
everywhere so far has been beautiful and
the attention to detail has been
impressive even in King's Landing this
episode they changed the set to match
the high towers and it being much colder
and stripped back kind of implying that
we're leaving the Golden Age and are
heading into darkness
thank you for watching as always and let
me know what you thought about episode 8
of House of the Dragon in the comments